hello welcome to this video pune [ __ ]
it's my opponent let's do something else
going for the Trump okay so i don't know
that opening yes well that I'm going for
a particular setup here now let people
have played against me when I was black
and somehow I always struggled so I'm
trying to set up myself now with g3 and
NC for later I quite often started an
attack with H file and so on but it
didn't really work out so well so let's
see what happens here so you going for
f5 no soft preparing c4 isn't that a
good position now for me I mean is Pawn
down on d5 looks weakish okay well i can
i can trade i mean is that set a bad
decision
and see so the thing that is a little
bit yeah question where are my
weaknesses on the dark squares I'm
playing this too I can't be sure before
you might have okay I think I'll go here
and try to regroup this the end game
that I want to play a something
something with Knights against bishop in
ideally let's see and 23 was a weird
choice actually but his is not trying to
use it in some way just goes along with
the trade so um let's see now night
should be over 2f form trying to regroup
it
95 d3 f-4s the idea and this is also a
good move putting it out of checks and
stuff well it gives me that with a tempo
it's surprising yeah I know I'm
threatening also to take and play Queen
d2 just winning the pawn a pawn
structure it's just much better okay
simply ignoring me here maybe I should
have played h4 and just yeah completely
take this idea out of the picture anyway
it's just down just a very good position
for wide so that looks good pinning the
night attacking d5 threatening walk c7
galaxy seven what's your move back with
the Queen I cannot do anything here
grabbing the b7 power next
black who've taken the book em I could
have taken the rook ok good thing is it
doesn't really matter that much look III
year maybe look III for for Queenie for
hmm now that is actually a bit of an
annoyance that check so I probably have
to take clean cheeks and then what Roxy
three yeah that's not not that's not so
clear actually remarkable
a stupid stuff and shouldn't have
allowed that in the first place here so
takes Queen takes their roots II to
Queen avoids it's a problem I have an
exceptional talent yeah I'm making
things more difficult for me then then
they need to be a it's a completely
clear fair and check then I still have
some I find some way to make it check I
get tricky and I came but it's pretty
clear now probably that resins rook
takes III wasn't objectively helping him
but it was like yeah just so clearly
over that it shouldn't ever happen
something here here and 296 it's much
easier even though that doesn't work
yeah the engine wants to take know our I
suspected that this should work somehow
but it looks kind of scary check the
engine says he has gone off with no
perpetual ma'am yeah probably if he's
checking hear something like 92 will be
an excellent defending setup okay but
how did it did it come to that bad
position for black there are a couple of
things on here okay well this is an
interesting way of playing I'm just
basically stating that my queen the my
king position is weak but I feel like my
play on them on his some weaknesses is
more important and I think that might be
true I mean around here I think why does
a bit better I'm just very comfortable
with my pawn structure being completely
without any weaknesses and he's got d5
week a little bit the double corn is
made the pawns themselves are not weak
but they have firm exposed some square
weaknesses likely five but also a five
yeah gives me that square on b5 and the
pawns are in general kind of weakish
yeah this this was a strange move yeah I
also felt that that around here you
should try to improve but it it was a
bit obliging I mean I wasn't quite sure
why you needed to take on c1 I mean you
can don't do this for example also the
night on v6s is on on his verse square
basically so maybe you can try to
regroup oh I know this one are probably
better to c6 try to plug the sea foam
around here I still think that I'm a bit
better but it's nothing serious okay
it's getting me the C file yeah now I
mean it looks kind of nice already this
is just strange I mean I want to go here
anyway so it gives me this and here the
computer is already giving me a winning
advantage yeah if he goes back here I
can just do this and how is he covering
this it's just not on that pawn is lost
and the structure as we said a couple of
times already is this excellent yeah TMP
I'm winning him he still has weaknesses
but now I'm a pawn up and have the
a more active piece placement okay
thanks for watching